for 27 years this has been Eunice
Howard's home
a house she built with her late husband
now ripped apart
a moment here of community support that
is replicated across this Valley and
Beyond
within 10 to 12 minutes I hear the noise
and I raise the window and I seen the
water and I knew I had to get out of
there
it was in the house and my building
started coming out I said well my house
will be okay about 10 miles to come out
took about five minutes for that to
happen five to six minutes and it was
gone from the time I got out of the
house
Eunice's granddaughter wanted to show us
the power of the water it's moved like
to 300 meters because the house didn't
used to be where it now sits so these
are the foundations yeah my God
from above it's clear the foundations
below and several hundred meters
Downstream what's left of the Howard
family home
it is one of so many destroyed by rains
and floods that everyone here says they
have never seen before
the state Governor has been absorbing it
all from the air this is remote Kentucky
hard to reach hard to help so many who
have lost everything
the number known not to have made it
continues to rise
and devastating stories
four children from the same family
pulled from their parents arms as they
sought safety on the roof of a home
which collapsed underneath them
down the valley Beyond Eunice's House
people salvaging what they can they will
all need to start all over again
but this is still a rescue operation as
a major disaster Federal funding has
been provided and Personnel too this is
still an emergency situation we are in
Search and and rescue mode but again
that account is going to continue to go
up and we don't lose as many people in
in flooding it's just a real tough one
it is a sentiment you hear over and over
now with so much extreme weather this
isn't normal Mark Stone Sky News in
Hazard Kentucky